[Music]
[Applause]
go to Mike Florio pro football talk live
co-host and contributor to football
night America
oh look who's got a kiss a kiss coffee
cup
I got it all
not not all of it not the coffin yet but
yeah I was a member of the KISS Army I
spent the five dollars I had the badge I
had all the stuff when you're 10 11
years old
mid 70s yeah turn on the Poland
Halloween special on ABC at 8 pm Eastern
on a Friday night and these guys come
out with the fire and the brimstone and
the explosions they don't care about the
quality music you just this is awesome
there's nothing else like it the music
grows on you after about 20 years and
music is right the experience is what's
great I agree I agree with that did you
ever see kiss in concert nine times
the best one was in 1996 when they
reunited and they put the makeup back on
I went up to Pittsburgh to see him with
a good friend of mine and it was like 20
years it just disappeared they could
still move like I saw them a few years
ago and they're having a little trouble
getting around the stage you know but
but in 96 they could still actually move
in those giant shoes and and it was like
seeing them in the 70s so I saw them
several times in the 70s several times
since then I went to their most recent
farewell tour because they've been on a
farewell tour for the last 20 years and
and it really is tough to watch now but
it was magical back in the 90s and back
in the 70s and 80s did you wear the
makeup no one time one time Halloween
1978 my sister put the cat man Peter
Chris makeup on me
for trick or treat all right that's all
I wanted to talk to you about Mike I got
plenty of
money I could blame
for profootballtalk.com because 21 years
ago when I was trying to figure out what
I'm going to do in this business I
remembered what I heard Paul Stanley say
early in the existence of Kiss they
created the show that they would pay
money to go see and that's such a simple
message to anyone who's in any type of
service business make the thing whatever
it is that you would be a customer of
make it the way that you would want it
if you were the one deciding where
you're going to spend your time and
there's Brilliance to that and it worked
music wasn't great but but it worked
over the past 50 years we're talking to
Mike Florio pro football talk live
co-host with Chris Sims that precedes us
on peacock before I get to the
commanders Giants Terry McLaurin
controversy here I was talking about
Sean McVeigh and I was wondering if he
can see enough in Baker Mayfield over
the next couple of weeks here that he
would go you know what he's worth
staying around for maybe that's my
future here depending on what happens
with Matthew Stafford and then I
wondered you know the TV business had a
big rake reset here in the off-season
Mike with all of these jobs being filled
up and everybody getting their money
that I wonder if Sean McVay
has an opening here where he'd go this
is a soft Landing right now because I
don't want to stick around for this
rebuild with the Rams your thoughts well
the question Dan is how how long until
they can rebuild how long are the debts
going to be paid for the Super Bowl that
they won last year hey horrible season
this year your first round pick goes to
Detroit as the last piece of the Matthew
Stafford for Jared Goff swap so you
don't even get that so they've got cap
issues they've got veteran contracts
that are bloated they don't have draft
picks they don't have a nucleus of young
players that would be coming into their
Prime right now because they've traded
away all those first round picks they
haven't used a first round pick since
the year they selected Jared Goff and
they ultimately gave up a first round
pick to get his awful contract off the
books as part of that staff would trade
so it could take years for the Rams to
turn it around and you're right McVay
has to be thinking number one did I miss
my chance with Amazon last year number
two is there another opportunity out
there now I mean I don't know Dan is a
network going to tear up and eat one of
these 15 20 million dollar contracts are
they going to wedge him into the booth
without Michael's and Kirk Herbstreit I
could see Amazon may be doing that going
with a three-man booth so I I if I'm
Sean McVeigh
did the right thing when I had the
chance to jump I wonder how long it's
going to take to turn this team around
and maybe now is the time to walk away
and then come back you know 10 15 years
from now all right the Terry McLaren
situation here with the commanders what
did you see on that play
well I saw what we see at every level of
football anyone who's paid any amount of
attention to what happens out on the
sidelines you see the receiver go out
communicate with the official who's on
that that line of scrimmage and there's
that back and forth whether it's verbal
or whether it's hand gestures or nodding
or shaking to get properly lined up I
saw Terry McLaurin believing that he was
getting guidance from the official who
was there I saw the official acting in a
way as if he was communicating back to
Terry McLaurin but then all of a sudden
you see the officials kind of like the
guy who's out at the okay Corral and
he's getting ready for the gun fight
he's got his hand he's got his hand on
the gun he's ready to pull it he puts
his hand on his flag like I'm gonna get
you I'm gonna get you and it's just a
bad look I know that John Hussey the
referee said after the game there's no
obligation on the part of the official
to tell but you surely can't mislead the
player it's one thing to say nothing
it's another thing to lead him to
believe that you're okay I'd love to
hear what was said between the two men
if anything but it just is a bad look
when you consider there are many ways
that one official can affect the outcome
of a game but when you throw that flag
away from the action that takes a
touchdown off the board in crunch time
that's a bad look for the NFL and that
was a moment Dan where I said maybe they
do need to worry about a potential Tim
Donahue situation at some point I'm not
saying it's happening now but that just
shows you there are ways that one person
can really affect the outcome of a game
I would think with all of these
Sidelines miked up
somebody and you know two huge media uh
cities here playing one another that
that would be we would have some kind of
dialogue there that's on tape well who
would have it who would have custody of
the NFL the NFL films yes it's like just
like the audio between miles Garrett and
Mason Rudolph it never came to light
that was very controversial about what
Mason Rudolph may have said or not said
before he was whacked over the head with
his own helmet that audio never came to
light even though audio is everywhere
yeah there are microphones everywhere
yeah there's probably audio and we'll
probably never hear
I'm wondering about Jalen hurts he's not
playing it looks like Gardner minshu is
going to get the start and if
is Jalen hurts going to lose the MVP
because he's not playing in the next two
games perhaps well I don't think it
helps him because as of right now and
the way that this award goes the
quarterbacks of the two number one seeds
are the two most likely candidates at
the end of the day unless somebody does
something crazy statistically like if
Justin Jefferson ends up with two
thousand or more yards and the Vikings
are the two seed then maybe you have to
consider him but it's either going to be
Josh Allen Patrick Mahomes or Joe burrow
depending upon which team in the AFC is
the one seed or Jalen Hearts so Jalen
hurts is out as the AFC race for the one
seed comes to a crescendo and we're
going to see something Spectacular from
Alan Omer Holmes or Borough it's going
to be hard for Hertz to get enough votes
when the dust settles if he hasn't
played at the end of the regular season
and why playing they're one game away
one win or a loss by the Vikings or
49ers or Cowboys from clinching the one
seed why take a chance they can win with
Gardner minshu so yeah I think it's
going to cost him the MVP not that he
cares about it I think he cares about
winning the Super Bowl but you know a
lot of people care about the MVP and I
think he's fallen out of the race if he
doesn't play but how much of this do you
think is the story that you can tell
broadcasters writers about the MVP that
we we love the story we've taken Mahomes
for granted now he's graduated into that
you know he's like The Greek Freak in uh
the NBA like okay nice story now we move
on there
um how much is what we get you know the
story behind that we haven't heard
well it's it's so odd because it is
subjective there are 50 different
individuals who will have their vote for
the first time it's not one vote per
person you put in five names and they
get ranked almost like the Heisman so it
could it's at least going to get people
some discussion and consideration you
know Russell Wilson would have had an
MVP vote by now if they had this system
in place back when he was you know
playing well I didn't mean to I didn't
mean to take a shot at myself well some
of them were just stating the office yes
of course
um I but I I think it's it's become this
pattern where it's a quarterback of one
of the top seeds that's just how it
shakes out because the voting happens
when immediately after the regular
season ends as we know what the playoff
tree looks like we know who's earned to
buy we have a certain amount of
heightened respect for the quarterback
of the team that has emerged from this
morass of competitors to be the number
one seed unless somebody does something
statistically crazy like Adrian Peterson
10 years ago when he almost broke the
single season rushing record and took it
away from Peyton Manning when Manning
was the odds on MVP that's the kind of
thing that does it otherwise it's
quarterback quarterback quarterback
quarterback It just fits better and
there's no guidelines there's no rules
it's just kind of how it goes
I was wondering about this last week
that we have NBA uh you know we've
changed the uh trophies and we've named
them after you know great players former
great players and if the NFL did this
the MVP could you name it the Peyton
Manning MVP the Super Bowl MVP would be
the Tom Brady award well it's already
the Pete Roselle award I think see the
problem with naming things what do you
do a hundred years from now when or 200
years from now I always worry about that
like what are they going to do when they
have 10 000 busts in the Hall of Fame
like you know like at some point retired
jerseys I'm big on that like at some
point like who's this jersey retired for
somebody that nobody who is currently
living can even remember I don't like
naming the awards unless it truly is
somebody that is going to be remembered
500 years
foreign
I'm not worried about that because I
won't be around to worry about that Mike
come on like what's gonna happen with
all the garbage it doesn't matter we'll
be dead
okay should Peter Chris be able to wear
his kiss makeup when he dies
inextricably intertwined with their
personas will choose to be buried in
their makeup that's the real question
Gene Simmons I I would imagine
right I I would think
I would think he and Paul Stanley would
both be be buried in their makeup I
think Gene Simmons will finagle it so
whatever Mausoleum he's in will like you
know once every hour just have a giant
Fireball explode at the top of it for
eternity
thank you Mike great to talk to you
happy holidays Dan thank you Mike Mike
Florio you too a pro football talk live